bueno hoy hemos ganado
hoy es un día de triunfo
los resultados están allí casi completos
ya a estas horas
le agradezco a los 90.000 testigos y
festivas que estuvieron acompañándonos
cuidando el
guardianes del voto
y yo creo que un millón de activistas
que a través de redes en las calles en
los barrios así fue según la frase
algunos y algunas
otros con enormes derroche de energía de
vida durante todo este tiempo han hecho
posible en todas las regiones de
colombia
el qué
hoy seamos millones 8 millones 500 mil
ciudadanos y ciudadanas de colombia
victoriosos en esta primera vuelta
más del 40% si se compara con las cifras
de hace cuatro años ni hablemos del
doble
si se comparaba con las cifras del 13 de
marzo nuestra reciente intervención
en el caso particular mío es casi
duplicar mí
casi llegar aquí
a duplicarlo
2.700.000 otros más de toda la consulta
del pacto histórico
es un crecimiento indudable en las tres
regiones
que previmos iban a ser victoriosas y
que nos incluso por sus porcentajes
hubieran podido permitir que ganáramos
en la primera vuelta presidencial
tengo que agradecerle a todo ese pueblo
nariñense caucano
[Aplausos]
más del 70 por ciento del electorado-
nariñense y cauca no votaron por
nosotros
[Aplausos]
no soy no soy de nariño no soy del cauca
pero ojalá que esos vientos del sur
recorran toda colombia ahora en estas
tres semanas
[Aplausos]
y el electorado del choco del valle del
cauca
allí tuvimos nuestra
mejor nuestro mejor resultado
a mi pueblo del caribe colombiano
[Aplausos]
nos ayudó firme digno
veo miguel ángel del río que encabezó la
lucha contra la compra del voto y tuvo
un gran éxito
en toda esa región todos todos los
departamentos del caribe
tuvimos una victoria
le pido
a los ciudadanos y ciudadanas
costeñas que votaron por otras
candidaturas esta vez con petro primer
presidente costeño
progresista de colombia
esta vez
así es ahora no nos habían acompañado
ahora toca llegó el momento de que la
costa determine el cambio de colombia
[Aplausos]
una invitación que les hago a toda esa
comunidad que quiero tanto la comunidad
de gabriel garcía márquez
la de mis padres las de mis abuelos
y bogotá ni se diga
mi ciudad lo que goberné
buen tanto en todo el resto del país
nuestros contrincantes no es que son mal
administrador si fueron mal
administrador nos sacó el 50 por ciento
del electorado bogotano
que nos acompaña
y por el electorado bogotano fuese
seríamos presidentes lo cual significa
y un enorme respaldo de una población
que goberné y que ha evaluado lo
importante que sería para colombia toda
el que muchos de los ejes del gobierno
que nos guiaron a la ciudad durante la
bogotá humana se vuelva un gobierno
nacional
allí
nosotros municipios la amazonía toda que
espera al rescate de la selva amazónica
nos han acompañado el putumayo
amazonas y otros departamentos hemos
triunfado
en ese país
nos hemos acercado a triunfar en
cundinamarca
en boyacá en el tolima en el huila ojalá
estos departamentos
que son tan cercanos a la idea del
programa agrario que les hemos
presentado de poder comprar las cosechas
de poder vender en los barrios donde
está el hambre
reconstituyendo el dilema de poder
volver al campesino a la familia
campesina
una familia más próspera propietaria
colectiva de procesos de
agroindustrialización
es en cundinamarca es en boyacá es en el
tolima es en el huila don es la en la
altillanura
donde este programa tendría más rápida y
eficaz ejecución
y por eso les solicito a esos
departamentos
acompañarnos mayoritariamente en esta
campaña que viene y que debe determinar
el cambio de colombia lo que se disputa
hoy es el cambio
los partidos políticos aliados al
gobierno de educ
el presidente duque
sus proyectos políticos ha sido
derrotado en color
[Aplausos]
yo creo que la votación total de
colombia lo que lanza es ese mensaje
central al mundo se acaba un periodo se
acaba una era
[Música]
finalizó finalizó mal en medio de la
trampa en medio de los suyos
pero finalizó
ahora se trata de construir un futuro
ahora se trata de ver qué es lo que
vamos a hacer con colombia
qué es lo que lo que la sociedad
colombiana quiere de su propio país
en qué consistiría es el cambio
algunos uribistas decían con el cambio
no querían que cambiara el país pero
tenían cierta razón
ojo con el cambio puede haber cambios
que son
alzar una roca y dejarla caer en los
pies
popularmente le dicen tirarse un tiro al
pie
hay cambios que son al vacío hay cambios
que no son cambios son suicidios
nosotros queremos invitar a toda la
sociedad colombiana a ser un cambio de
verdad
un cambio hacia adelante
un cambio constructivo un cambio que nos
permita una era nueva
mucho más próspera de mucho más
bienestar de mucha más capacidad
tanto para el pueblo como para la nación
colombiano
hoy se define a partir de ahora de estos
minutos qué clase de cambios del que
queremos
sí suicidarnos o avanzar
yo pienso y creo que debemos avanzar yo
le digo aquí a ese empresariado temeroso
que estuvo en estos meses con el que
dialogue muchas veces
prácticamente con todos los gremios
gente poderosa y no tan poderosa con
pequeños y medianos empresarios de
colombia al cual les decían una serie de
sandeces para que no votaran por
nosotros o se asustaron
yo les diría bueno ha llegado un momento
de escoger
yo lo que propongo a la empresa de
empresariado es justicia social y
estabilidad económica
estabilidad económica hoy significa dado
los resultados
justicia social
no puede crecer una empresa si la
sociedad se empobrece
no puede crecer las ganancias en
realidad de manera sostenible si la
mayoría de la población de aumentar el
hambre su estómago en su organismo en
sus familias en sus comunidades
no es saltar al vacío es la estabilidad
económica me sorprendían los debates por
los que he pasado
que el único que planteaba una opción
para disminuir el déficit fiscal casi
que la quiebra del estado en que nos ha
dejado duque era yo
bueno para alcanzar estabilidad
económica hay que disminuir el déficit
fiscal
y para disminuir el déficit fiscal
necesitamos una tributación de parte de
ellos que nos permita hacer crecer la
justicia social que nos permita que toda
la juventud colombiana pueda ir a la
universidad
dos millones y medio de jóvenes hoy no
pueden hacerlo
si lo logramos las empresas serán más
grandes
habrá más productividad podremos
concentrar conocimiento y ciencia en la
agricultura en la industria en el
turismo la producción crecerá luego las
ganancias crecerán pero también el
salario pero también el ingreso de los
colombianos pero también el bienestar
general de la sociedad
es un programa económico el que hemos
presentado como hemos presentado un
programa de justicia social para
colombia no es estrafalario pensar que
se puede construir de nuevo en colombia
el derecho a la pensión no es
estrafalario el que se puedan llevar
médicos para prevenir la enfermedad
no es estrafalario el que podamos decir
que la educación superior se convierte
en derecho
la justicia social no es estrafalario en
colombia es una necesidad
claro a esa necesidad nos lleva no
llegaremos si hay corrupción
pero la corrupción no se combate con
frases de dicto
[Aplausos]
así algunas personas muy respetables
piensen que sí
la corrupción se combate arriesgando la
vida
porque es un régimen de corrupción lo
que enfrentamos
nosotros hemos arriesgado la vida para
luchar contra la corrupción más de
mentiras es de verdad
no estamos aquí para engañar con un
discurso sino para plantear las
realidades sobre la mesa y decirle a la
sociedad colombiana con claridad hacia
dónde vamos
no queremos más violencias
hemos propuesto un camino de
pacificación
hace cuatro años cuando disputábamos con
duque por estas mismas épocas
la mayoría de la sociedad
aparentemente decidió que el camino no
era la paz
que había que hacer trizas la paz plomo
es lo que hay dijeron por ahí en algún
momento
hoy cuál puede ser el balance
en ese entonces dijeron vamos a cerrarle
el camino a petro el camino es duque
para colombia hoy podemos hacer un
balance una evaluación que pasó con
cerrarle el camino al progresismo
colombiano y permitir que un proyecto
como el de duque permaneciera cuatro
años más en el poder hoy tenemos más
violencia hoy tenemos más corrupción hoy
tenemos
más hambre violencia corrupción y hambre
valía la pena cerrarle el camino al
progresismo por temor a un cambio que
nos llevará más bien a la paz a un
estado transparente ya una sociedad más
democrática y productiva
yo creo que la sociedad colombiana tiene
que analizar hoy la decisión para los
próximos cuatro años
queremos más violencia
queremos más corrupción
me contradictorio está
imputado por corrupción
es lo que queremos
no es un proceso de mentiras son unos
indicios reales
seguimos por ahí
seguimos por el camino de las frases
huecas
mientras lo que se encubre es mantener
las cosas como están
y aletargados cuatro años más el cambio
verdadero de colombia'
aletargar cuatro años más el cambio
verdadero de colombia solo significará
más destrucción de la paz que significa
muchos más muertos significará más
estancamiento económico por no pasar a
construir una economía productiva a
transitar hacia las energías limpias a
posibilitarnos y colocarnos en medio de
la humanidad como toda la humanidad está
luchando en una economía descarbonizada
en una sociedad del conocimiento
el cerebro de los colombianos decía en
mi discurso y de las colombianas no es
diferente al de los norteamericanos no
es diferente al de los chinos no es
diferente al de los europeos porque
tenemos que condenar a nuestra sociedad
a mas
ignorancias inducidas por gobiernos que
no quieren financiar la educación
pública y que entonces hacen gala de la
superficialidad de la falta de argumento
porque creen que las sociedades se
pueden manejar como rebaños si no se
educan
porque no damos un salto en el
conocimiento hacia adelante porque no
permitimos que la ciencia pueda gobernar
con el presidente porque no permitimos
que las mujeres
no se queden en la casa y puedan
cogobernar con el presidente
porque pretendemos que una sociedad
entonces es aquella en donde los hombres
gobiernen y las mujeres cocinan
eso no es de hace dos siglos eso no es
lo que hay que superar
colombianos y colombianas es el momento
de llegar a una modernidad si somos una
ciudadanía libre
seremos una gran nación podremos crear
podremos inventar no es la hora del
cambio real
quién puede considerar que el cambio
real consiste en tener
centenares de miles de familias
esclavizadas pagando créditos
hipotecarios porque a los dueños de esos
apartamentos y casas les parece
delicioso que los hombrecitos y las
mujercitas como dicen ellos paguen 15
años al propietario multimillonario
hasta poder tener una casa
queremos
que esa es la sociedad que puede
construir justicia social que ese es el
cambio entonces el cambio consiste en
tener a las mujeres en la casa
mientras los hombres gobiernan y atender
a los deudores esclavizados entre
comillas disque deliciosamente pagando
la hipotecas a los banqueros existe el
cambio solo que ha habido durante dos
siglos en colombia
ustedes creen que el cambio puede ser
ciudadanas y ciudadanos de colombia que
podremos llegar a la paz que podremos
llegar a la convivencia que podremos ser
una gran nación
si admiramos a hitler
pues entonces ya tenemos
unos caminos que escoger
nosotros hemos propuesto
un cambio real y estable
un cambio verdadero un cambio en donde
la familia que es la primera comunidad
pueda fortalecerse
la familia como primera comunidad se
fortalece si la comida llega a la casa
si frenamos importaciones caras para
producir en colombia le explicamos el
pueblo caribeño si dejamos de importar 6
millones de toneladas de maíz del norte
podemos
producir 250 mil puestos de trabajo en
los campos de colombia y beneficiar a un
millón de personas
llevar comida a la casa si la mayoría de
nuestra población
gana menos de 3000 pesos diarios y un
litro de leche vale 3000
mayoristas
y un kilo de carne 38 mil como come el
pueblo
y si no hay propuestas como las que
hemos hecho subsidiar los fertilizantes
reedificar el idioma comprar las
cosechas y llevarlas al barrio pobre
entonces como se acaba el hambre
con frases de tick tock
yo creo que aquí nos toca ponerlos muy
seriamente en la tarea de decidir qué
cambio quiere colombia nosotros queremos
un cambio que construye aquí paz
que acabe la violencia que le diga a la
mamá que no tenga miedo ya de que su
hija y su hijo salgan a la calle y pasen
esos días de inseguridad de temor a
veces de terror en muchas partes de
colombia
nosotros lo que queremos aquí es
justicia social
que el viejo y la vieja savia tengan
pensión y que todos los niños y niñas de
colombia tengan nutrición
leche carne porque no es que el conjunto
de la sociedad pueda tener salud a
través de llevar los médicos a la casa
porque no que toda nuestra juventud si
es que queremos una nación grande en 20
30 años que compita entre los pueblos
del mundo pueda acceder a la educación
superior y a la universidad
esos propósitos son fundamentales para
la sociedad colombiana y yo les solicito
a la mayoría de esta sociedad colombiana
que nos sigamos como estamos
que no nos hundamos más en la violencia
en la corrupción
y en la injusticia que no demos un salto
al suicidio que es el tiempo de la vida
no del suicidio que el cambio es por la
vida porque lo que buscamos es una
colombia potencia mundial de la vida así
que
estamos a un millón de votos de ganar
un millón de votos más
de estos 8 millones y medio de lectores
si esta cifra cambia el 8 por un 9
ganamos
cambiando esa colombia
luego el objetivo en todas partes
de nuestra militancia querida de este
activismo tanto en redes como en la
calle y en la vereda y en el edificio es
buscar ese millón más
allá están
están entre los que no votaron por
nosotros en el caribe colombiano que
pueden elegir
[Música]
están
incluso del pueblo antioqueño que hoy
votó por federico
es un pueblo laborioso que yo conozco
conservador de antaño no es tonto no es
bobo no va a llevar a colombia al
suicidio sabe que es eso
los invito a acercarse a nosotros a
entendernos a dialogar a juntarnos en
una posibilidad de transformación
invito a toda esa ciudadanía del huila
del tolima de cundinamarca que fue el
departamento que me eligió por primera
vez al congreso de la república
del boyacá e industrial y agrario que
aquí es donde está la posibilidad de un
desarrollo de una prosperidad agraria
invito al pueblo de norte de santander
sino reactivamos económicamente a cúcuta
y eso pasa por recuperar la frontera y
relacionarnos con el vecino lo que hay
es crisis económica entonces
invito al santander
al que gritó abajo el mal gobierno e
inició con su marcha hacia bogotá la
república en esa gesta de los comuneros
que nos volvamos de nuevo comuneros
porque toca de nuevo de evitar abajo el
mal gobierno y reconstruir como decía
por belice ser gaitán moral y
democráticamente la república llegó el
tiempo de la vida no hay paso atrás
sólo necesitamos un millón de votos más
invito a toda esta militancia y
activismo a conquistar
a
convencer
convencer con tranquilidad a convencer
con amor a la familia a convencer con
amor a la comunidad en la que se vive o
en la que se estudia para lograr lo que
esta generación puede darle a la
historia de colombia el primer gobierno
popular y democrático el primer gobierno
de un verdadero cambio pacífico el
primer gobierno quizás
transparente y decente en estos tiempos
gracias voy amar
[Aplausos]